(CROWD CHEERING
ALANIS MORISSETTE:
People would say,
"Wow, you're so brave,
you're so empowered."
(CROWD APPLAUDING)
MORISSETTE:
I can't write all these songs
without obviously having been
disempowered.
We couldn't get signed.
Everybody rejected us.
It's too in your face,
it's too emotional.
I am mad right now,
and when I'm 34,
you won't get a record
like that.
♪ (SINGING
"ONE HAND IN MY POCKET") ♪
SPEAKER: Was there room
for Alanis in rock? No.
But you try to ignore
the song.
You're not gonna write
a better song
than "You Oughta Know".
They put in a cassette tape.
Within 30 seconds,
everything changed.
And it just went nuclear, man.
It was like-- it went nuclear.
♪ (CROWD SINGING "IRONIC) ♪
MORISSETTE: Empowerment
as a young woman in the '90s,
singing about it was not
good news for the patriarchy.
You were just immediately
shut down.
SHIRLEY MANSON:
When you are the only woman
in a male dominated environment,
it's very complicated
and complex.
SPEAKER 2: Her brutal honesty
empowered women.
It gave you a chance to let out
your own feelings.
KEVIN SMITH:
This is a female artist
that transcended gender,
where dudes could be like,
"I feel the same way."
MORISETTE: Without even
knowing I was doing it,
I was carving out my voice.
This is dream come true stuff.
♪ 'Cause I've got one hand
In my pocket ♪
♪ And the other one is hailing
A taxicab ♪
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪
(CROWD CHEERING)